قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه
ابلغت الاداره الامريكيه موقفها الثابت من
القضيه الفلسطينيه وانه لن تكون هناك
علاقات دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل ما لم يتم
الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله على
حدود عام 67 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
وايقاف العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
وانسحاب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منه وردا على
تصريحات للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي بخصوص مسار السلام العربي
الاسرائيلي قالت الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيان ان موقف المملكه ثابت تجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وضروره حصول الشعب الفلسطيني
الشقيق على حقوقه المشروعه واورد البيان
ان المملكه تؤكد دعوه المجتمع الدولي
والدول الدائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن
للاسراع في الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه
على حدود عام
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
da